cargos a move that takes place in
post-apocalyptic Australia will be
witnessed the aftermath of a virus
outbreak that turns the infected into
zombie like creatures today the video
will focus on explaining the virus
itself rather than explaining the entire
movie but there will most likely still
be spoilers so if you get to see the
movie and you don't want to be spoiled I
urge you to please click away now when
we do eventually see those who have been
infected by this outbreak they do seem
to have some of the tropes that we would
associate with generic zombie creatures
such as being drawn towards blood and
having the urge to feast on flesh
the most common way of one being
affected by this cargo virus seems to be
either through a scratch or a bite by
one of the infected and these infected
do seem to be quite slow hobbling around
making it quite easy for them to be
outrun by any form of vehicle there are
a few things that make these zombies
from cargo stand out from what we would
generally expect these Dombey seem to
need rest and they seek dark places when
they slumber which is why we sometimes
see them with their head buried in dirt
almost like an ostrich bearing its head
in sand which also earned them the
nickname diggers the government in cargo
do seem to be aware of this virus
outbreak and when K becomes infected she
pulls out some kind of kit that is
clearly targeted towards those who have
been infected it comes complete with a
pamphlet that shows us some of the
symptoms of the virus which include
fever nausea seizures and vomiting all
things that we see throughout the movie
the kit also contains a wrist timer that
is set to 48 hours making it clear that
this is how long it takes for one to
become an undead zombie lastly we do see
some kind of pen that allows infected to
take their own lives if they didn't wish
to turn those who have been infected
seem to protrude an orange area of
sludge from their wounds in their face
and that later stages of the infection
their face is almost entirely caked in
this slime like substance the substance
does almost make the virus seem like is
closely tied to nature as it personally
reminds me of sap fusion from a tree now
as for the actual causes of the virus we
are given a few hints throughout the
movie well let's a believe that
chemicals may have been exposed by
mining company using the technique known
as fracking which many believe to be
quite bad for the environment this ties
into the explanation that were given by
the clever man who says that man is
poisoning the earth and as a result the
earth or poison man so it's very
possible that some kind of gas or virus
may have been exposed by this mining
company when digging through poisoned
land
the virus would most likely than been
carried airborne and once enough are
infected it will then spread through
biting and scratching
unlike most zombie films there doesn't
seem to be a cure for the virus
I'm almost given the impression that
nature will run its course when man
stops poisoning the earth the earth will
stop poisoning man and the virus will
disappeared hopefully I've been able to
answer any questions that you may have
had about the virus and if there are any
other movies you would like me to cover
that please let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained